this is a lot of fun like this movie is
crazy it's blockers uh and there's so
much going on and this character
uh so many people love i remember
reading in the comics for the first time
when i was a kid and being absolutely
terrified
and you just bring them to life on
screen with so much energy what was your
approach to embodying cleo's cassidy
well you know i i approached even though
you know it
it's in the marvel universe i approach
it kind of similar to how i would
generally approach a character which is
to think about you know why have they
turned out the way they have
you know what are the influences from
childhood
uh and you know i think with most serial
killers you find they didn't get a lot
of love so in a way that kind of uh
that that's
part of his
seeking out tom hardy's character
because you know
he wants a friend
and he thinks this would be my friend
you know
and tom is so invested in this in so
many ways and his performance is so um
it's so engaging what was it like going
toe-to-toe to him with his eddie
brock well
you know from the time i saw him
i think it was in warriors uh
many years ago i i thought this
this guy tom hardy this is the new
brando and i do think he's he's of the
caliber
he's he's one of the great actors and
so
i always wanted to work with them so it
was really a privilege when they you
know they called me to do that little
thing at the end of the first one
and uh you know and this one obviously
we got more to do together i i think
he's uh
he's really fun to work with he's
he is a unique awesome actor
when the camera when the cameras stop
rolling are you guys still in it like
are you guys still doing your uh in
character thing or is it laugh on set
what's it like
no we we
we don't we had didn't stay in character
when the when they said cut
we just kept we got a lot of laughing
he's very funny guy
very funny guy great sense of humor
when we saw that tease
at the end of the first movie everyone
kind of went a little bit nuts like a
little bit crazy did you feel that did
you did you
feel that sort of love and the
anticipation from the audience for what
this movie was going to be even years
before they even saw it coming
no no i
i had no idea about it till you just
told me uh
you know i mean i i don't i don't really
go online and read these things or i i
don't know how i would have known if i
didn't do that so
uh
but you know that's cool because i i
sure enjoyed playing them and i i'm glad
i got to do this
there's
uh this thing about commentable
characters where regardless of um
whether they live or die in a storyline
they always come back in one way or
another
could you see yourself
being cletus cassidy in carnage again in
uh in the future
easily i could see that absolutely
[Laughter]
there's a lot of other people i'm hoping
they see it too you know the people who
make these decisions but
if not it was a great ride just getting
to do this
and it's a great ride seeing you do it
man it's a lot of fun thanks so much for
the time
thank you take care
you